la paire émission de l'année quelle est
la meilleure émission de l'année
dites-nous hashtag des pmp vérité vous
pour vous c'est quoi
strike a beau merci je suis producteur
on peut tout dire dans cette région
c'est sur ces huit léger je suis
producteur cette immersion d'ailleurs ça
va revenir en janvier
bassékou la lazio strike voila voila
merci merci à vous la gaffe c'est avec
toi sur la garde à bien oui j'ai trouvé
ça nul à mais complètement nue je trouve
que c'est ringard ça n'a aucun intérêt
c'est un pétard mouillé de la fesci sur
le départ dont les personnes à garder ou
alors je vous dis ça fait des très
bonnes audiences mine de rien le
mercredi 1er ça reste ça reste des mines
des meilleures audiences le mercredi sur
la quinzaine dit si je me trompe mais si
vous n'aimez pas si vous prônez la
grille le bowling
j'adore le bowling pour autant ah oui
ouais c'est ma gueule alors souvenez
vous il y avait de très bons invités de
personnes et c'est ça ya un moment pour
être crédible peut y aller
layar moment et fait nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
3 5 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors bien bien bien
j'ai appris à me solanet frontières a
dit gagné
nos produits la jurade et pour votre
concours